est ce que vous connaissez le 8 machines
on va passer tout de suite au mode dite
machine c'est parti il fâché
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est une machine et pour tout il patine
bien sûr moi vous avez reconnu je suis
baba
mais pour le hit machine il faut qu'il
faut charlie c'est parti un peu d'espoir
pour charlie qui est allé tout seul
[Applaudissements]
tu t'appelles ça vaut la peine charlie
jeu m'a dit je m'appelle charlie et je
m'appelle rabat on est sur ces 8 pour le
match le samedi aux compagnies
confondues
[Applaudissements]
alors venir la science au classement sur
le classement des plus grands tubes du
match lui qui a une petite gastro et là
on n'a pas pu venir mais charlie et la
malheureuse aussi connu l'une au bape
millions t'embrasse et on sait que d'où
tu es tu ne peux pas nous voir c'est pas
faux sur twitter et vous suffit de voter
bien sûr ce qu'on va voir les meilleurs
titres
il vous suffit de voter pour nous dire
qui est pour vous le meilleur groupe
avec le hashtag qu'est pmp hit machine
plus le nom du chroniqueur que vous avez
préféré les chiffres on va commencer
tout de suite avec c'est le dernier du
classement
oui malheureusement il nous vient d'où
je crois que nous vivons vit exactement
ils sont trois et sont trois exactement
comme les cinq doigts de la main voilà
c'était lé rocco siffredi ils arrivent
avec leurs énormes tubes à ceux des
ragots d'esterra c'est parti léo zones
sont avec nous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et donc
sylla à l'eau
sénèque
picasso y suivre les combats
genou
non
[Musique]
g
la beauté
[Applaudissements]
autant on adore la musique autant on
adore la musique autant au niveau du
costume ils sont pas foulés ni de la
perruque
donc merci vous pouvez vous mettre là
avant d'ajouter des bosses 30 jun avait
à peu près les mêmes que sinon ils sont
pas fait trop d'efforts au niveau de la
perruque tout ça à mon avis ça se la
raconte http mp de machines pour savoir
qui étaient les meilleurs les shihri mon
charlie on va passer à la rappeuse a
plus célèbre de france
ah bah oui celles qui aiment les
boulettes est exactement les mêmes les
boulettes elle aime les jo ging on a
pensé à qui bien sûr tout ça tombe bien
les deux elle a les deux à la plus de
boulettes que de jogging jaune ans
d'applaudir diam's valérie vous l'ex
[Applaudissements]
c'est paniquant qui nous avait fait
aucun blanc non
ce n'est sûrement
layton annoncé par l'état qui nous a dit
que non non non c'est un an benhaim sur
la tête de ma mère
côté quand elle se met en dialecte on
dirait qu'elle est malade à la maison
grecque à la tôle médecin pour la mer
battu val a chanté vas-y attention
bandits alors remettez au début trois
dans les locaux de la police ya quinze
jours j'ai les mains le lendemain des
accords à vous d'en bas dans l'autre
c'est à dire
[Applaudissements]
hp qui a été le meilleur ce soir est pas
mal enfin c'est mieux ses biens qui
avait tué le job est les premiers les
premiers je vous dis moi je vous dit
tout je pourrais pas les supporter
fallait pas demander moins énervé
soriano énervés ils m'ont énervé benhaim
pas mal bon par contre on ne la mènera
du prat peyrot charlie je crois qu'on va
passer à la 6e il a marqué lui aussi
vite machine
ah ouais alors bah oui ah oui ah oui je
confirme
ah oui oui bah moi je n'avais pas tu le
trouves alors des tissus non sur l'huile
en droit et en sixième position cette
semaine tu devrais pourrait on n'est pas
encore prêt pour transcender
c'est une artiste aux cheveux de feu
comme jean-michel mais pas et que sais
je
sa chanson on l'oublira jamais non et
bien sûr non elle est avec moi l'oubli
larusso et là isabelle a rouvert
c
[Applaudissements]
oui
ma
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
excusez moi juste devenu si vous
chercher le bois c'est tout tu khadra
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
comment ça commence mais qui sait que
cette tenue
c'est pas non spécifique franchement
isabelle morini bosc
nv mais au moins au moins vous auriez pu
faire les gestes
j'ai plus vu que vous oubliez de chanter
ah ouais bah c'est le problème ça à la
zone urbaine mais la bouche ouverte fait
à bord tout bas et ça c'est important
la vache et gijón au micro est-ce que je
les fais je vous rappelle je vous
rappelle qu'on a car micro dans
l'émission donc forcément ils doivent se
le passer les chéris donc voilà je suis
là si je le fais tomber on dépose le
bilan
c'est bien simple je fais tomber le
micro c'est terminé je veux faire genre
s'était pas c'était cirad est tout pour
moi elle est nerveuse à aller les chéris
alors justement voilà alors là on
parlait du talent ça pour moi c'est mon
préféré
je suis sûr que tu écoutais sambo a mais
j'écoutais ça en boucle cg de dire je
n'ai qu'une chose à tenir donne moi ton
coeur de mes deux motos corps donne moi
ton beau vieux fond qu'on pense à qui
les chéris
[Applaudissements]
m
je
gbagbo
[Applaudissements]
k-maro camaro kamal kamal c'est
tellement ça passe franchement c'est ma
chanson préférée moi j'adore quand tu
chantes j'oubliais j'ai plus le moindre
souci j'ai le mal
il adore mais sans réel c'est magnifique
donne moi ton coeur des bétons corps
bébé vous avez pensé à tous que vous
avez sur des saints et moi ton camp bel
et bien oui oui
alors voilà bien longtemps la télé on
ferme les yeux c'est vrai c'est qu'apple
aurait franchement quand on les ouvre à
abala c'est autre chose là quand on les
ouvre là c'est patrick sébastien c'est
allé lècher alors assez fantastique mais
tout le monde
alors franchement c'est une bombe
atomique et dieu sait qui a commencé à
présenter le hit machine avant qu'on
arrive c'est vrai c'est une bonne info
est quand même le monde
dieu lui a donné la foi il m'a juste
donné des foies de volaille en salade
séquelles et winter
[Applaudissements]
j'ai dans le coeur
quoi
j'ai dans le coeur ceci ne nous met pas
m
on sait bien
sa peine
ah je suis plus une enfant j'en ai marre
ne plus jamais
j'en ai assez
pour m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'en ai assez je vais me paraît
s'il dit
[Musique]
je voulais passer
c'est
ce qui ne met pas au fond
tu m
[Applaudissements]
la nouveauté http patine pas mal non
s'ils croient pas mal franchement quelle
parole la bad est là et l'a poussé à
vous avez la fantasque à nouveau c'est
pas des alors là là allez franchement
voilà j'ai fait elle a fait les beaux
jours du hit machine
ah oui oui parce que les cadres ont aimé
beaucoup quand elles venaient c'est vrai
quand elles venaient parce que les
cadences jeu s'initie à la chatte et moi
lolita et on s'est dit qu'ils ont mieux
que daniel moreau d'où vient il que
daniel braud peut faire alizée ce matin
c'est arrivé comme une évidence il fera
jour eh bien regardez attention c'est
pas de sa faute
n'oubliez pas aller là c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
et de trois
[Rires]
[Musique]
m
je m'appelle au liban sous les chênes
obame
moi je m'appelle haut
l'état
pas mal
g data
sauf sur franchement nv vous êtes très
belle à chaud je n'ai jamais vous si
benzema milone gtoi bisous fierté est
d'aller y jeter sur eux alors je vais te
dire je connais les sillinger j'suis
visagiste net
je suis coiffeur visagiste me suis fabio
salsa chez nouveau fabio salsa
franchement été magnifique c'est cent
fois mieux là qu est ce qu a fait la
coupe est à vous avant ça c'est là que
c'est ce qu'on fait là on a coupé les
lignes c'est quoi donc on a une petite
coupe racontera carrie prejean qu'est ce
qu'on a fait au niveau du maquillage
rouge à lèvres c'est que c'est
magnifique chalet pas défini vous
continuez à voter les chais rien
franchement j'ai l'impression de revenir
ou entendu et machines à l'armée je vous
jure et là où les autres ils sont là
tous ces artistes ou ceyrac tous ces
artistes tout ça mais franchement oui
j'adore avec manet dès que vous
continuez à voter bien sûr http la chine
avec le nom du chroniqueur que vous avez
préféré et franche là pour l'instant
bravo à tous à part les premiers de
classe a les premiers je les déteste
d'état simon sous les noms mais ils
m'ont tout de suite sous les l'urss a
très bien travaillé pour moi je vous lis
pour moi la meilleure pour l'instant
c'est et daniel
la donne et on va terminer seul toit
chinon terminent toutes les semaines
bien sûr par les numéros un du
classement
non alors on me dit non apparemment apte
à ouidah il en reste encore un bail etc
ou à oui c'est vrai away avant avant on
allie numéro deux du classement font une
entrée fracassante cette semaine ils
sont directement deuxième c'est alors si
les tribal king
non mais bien sûr je suis obligé de le
dire parce que tu vois la tête qu'ils
ont les tribal king et eux ils ont une
façon très particulière de chansons de
chanter ils chantent façon sec son sexe
ça alors je vous le dis c'est un de mes
titres préférés mais j'ai écouté ça à
fond pendant des années et des années
c'est un kiff de ouf ils nous font
l'honneur d'être avec nous ce soir c'est
pas les tribal king lasser les laiteries
car king regardez ils sont là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je
c'est
[Musique]
suivez moi juste bonheur aux stylistes y
avait pas de budget perruque sur cette
séquence très bas de budget perruque
merci en tout cas et c'est combien
beaucoup de ses combats ses ce micro la
c4 à merde que 4,10 à l'économie et
bravo m
non non non on a eu aussi des pointeurs
désolé mais alors est ce qu'on peut en
voir attendent un port on peut leur
chanter c'est un peu là on peut remettre
le promoteur s'il vous plaît attention
remettez le prompteur et rome était la
chanson elle et elle est exceptionnelle
allez y au moins qu'on kiffe un peu la
chanson
excusez moi les mecs mais vous l'avez
prise ou l'ascension pourquoi on
l'entend comme ça non mais ça ils ont
été aperçus youtube cette bande doit
[Rires]
savoir prendre le titre
non mais regardez moi cette production
donc mal comme on n'a jamais vu ça vient
ils ont dû voir un mec qu'a posté la
vidéo aujourd'hui avec 17 buts herrmann
et nous l'ont balancé à l'hôtel non mais
c'est pas possible d'être mal par l ai
trahis par la technique maintenant mais
c'est pas possible
et c'est ce que voulait ce qu'il y
faisait mais pas meilleure qualité n'y
avait pas meilleur producteur aussi les
mecs j'ai écouté pendant des années
cette chanson loi besson et voilà il me
flinguer tribaux thing toi tu d'ailleurs
pourquoi pas aider faut pas le dire ça
comme ça ils ont essayé ils ont fait
saison bravo vous en dirai billy
crawford
ça n'a rien à voir mais c'est vrai je
redis à la messagerie et et franchement
le style rappeur vous va très bien lyon
ça ça allait on laisse passer les cherry
on va accueillir dakar le numéro un du
classement et c'est pour moi ce sont
vraiment les numéros un des numéros un
ils sont indétrônables tu les connais
bien le boys band qui met le feu
ils sont beaux ils sont drôles c'est lé
top boys ils nous chantent le feu brûle
encore oui le feu ça brûle et sont avec
nous ce soir
applaudissements pour eux
et
vous
[Musique]
c
le feu ça brûle
[Applaudissements]
les spécialistes à ce soit y aura le p4
issa doumbia jusqu'à 30 et entre cinq
cartons spectacle mais après il y aura
un doc sur issa et la soirée alors
qu'est ce que je peux dire un truc je ne
savais pas que tu venais pas voulu c'est
une surprise
voilà et 2 ils savent fait les les voies
ou mieux que moi bah oui parce qu'ils
ont veillé h en tout cas ces deux
d'avoir cette tenue est que tout le
monde pense que c'est vraiment ma tenue
[Applaudissements]
alors je voudrais dire aux
téléspectateurs c'était vraiment une
surprise pour charlize theron s'est dit
malade je serai pas là il m'a dit qu'il
avait une gastro voilà et pas du tout
qu'il allait devoir du cru et voilà il
est agréé 91 soit bien qu'on va bien ça
fait longtemps dans cette rue
donc j'ai eu ou non s'est vu la semaine
dernière oui nous en avons gardé contact
être énonce le dr charles élus qui sont
avec nous ils sadoum bien aussi vous
votez on va voir tout de suite les
résultats qui arrivent en tête qui a
gagné eh bien ces valeurs
[Applaudissements]
attention